hey my name is Samuel Leeds and on this
video I'm gonna share with you some ways
how you can save on stamp duty Stamp
Duty is one of those really annoying
taxes that sometimes you just have to
pay but sometimes you don't and a lot of
people are massively overpaying
thousands and thousands of pounds in
stamp duty when they don't have to so I
mean let me give you some examples okay
and honestly if this saves you money and
you end up saving a lot of money then
please do tell me and thank me because I
do these videos partly just to feel good
about saving can help and make you money
okay there's a few ways I'll start with
this one if you're buying a house bother
what if some juice times you is just if
you buy a house it's just like a tax
basically like one of those annoying
things so that's what it is
the maguey news story of buying a house
and I thought it was a HMO it was worth
a hundred and thirty five thousand
pounds or if that's what I was buying it
for and I'd agreed to buy the house from
the seller and the stamp duty on that
was going to be I think it's like about
four and a half thousand pounds and I
spoke to the seller and I found out that
he owned the house but he owned it in a
company so instead of buying the house
what I did was I bought the company that
owns the house so this thing basically
the exact same thing because I was going
to have to set up a company to buy the
house or one by the house of my company
I just bought the company now what that
meant was I technically wasn't buying a
house I was buying a company which meant
that I paid put him I think it was 0.5%
Stan GT so the stamp G went down to like
hundreds of pounds stead of thousands
and I thought that was pretty cool so
now every time I'm buying a house I'd
always ask the question is it owned by
an individual or a company and if it's
owned by a company it might be better
and of course ask your tax advisor on
this and your accountant but it might be
better and it might save you some duty
by buying the company instead of the
house all right next way if it's less
than 40 thousand pounds
you weren't placed on duty and ever so
if the house has less than 40 grand
you're not gonna pay stamp jury next is
if you want multiple houses
wants and again this sure that the
solicitors often just don't tell you you
mean you might be buying five six seven
houses you're buying them all in one
girl you could be buying them from the
same seller and if you're doing that
then again your stamp duties gonna gonna
almost completely disappear but make
sure that you sell it make sure you
fight your solicitor on this guest list
is it's creative that's gonna try and
figure out how to say if you wanted a
magician always question it don't just
pay without questioning it so if you boy
lots of houses at once I think it's six
or more but then it brings the stamp
duty to almost zero next I'll get oh
yeah and I'm giving you examples bother
this is all from experience this is not
stuff that I read in the book and I'm
not interested in this he's stuff that
I've I've been buying a house and I
figured this out myself all my
solicitors who's been working with me on
it isn't even for me when I was buying
the castle the stamp duty on the castle
was going on goodness it was like a
killer because I already owned houses
it's a massive investment there are tax
in the crap out of me on that and I'll
speak to my solicitor so how can I save
stamp duty on buying this castle and
here's what we did because the castle
it's one castle but because it's it will
had multiple dwellings in it and we had
planning permission already for it to
form or lots of different apartments and
houses it's one purchase but we've got
something called multiple dwelling
relief which brought that which saved I
think that saved just about forty five
thousand pounds
forty five thousand pounds on stamp duty
I mean true that's enough to go and buy
another house you know they deposit on
that so there's some ways is less than
the threshold of forty grounds behind
lots of houses at once potentially
multiple dwelling if you're buying if
you want to buy a company instead of the
house there's a few creative ways you
can save you can save or eliminate stamp
duty but I wouldn't get so hung up about
it if you're buying look if you buy in
the right house and it's a good
investment it's going to be making you
good money and you're gonna get hit a
few thousand pound with the stamp duty
sometimes you just have to take it on
the chin and just think you know what
within three months or
along the stub Juhi's all going to be
paid for I think it's probably better to
focus most of your energy on how to make
money rather than how to save money but
I thought that'd be helpful I thought I
had to share that with you guys because
you know saving that kind of money like
forty-five thousand pound on one
purchase and there's many times where
it's a normal solicitor would just bill
me and even if you if you are not sure
just find out you know go on the website
speak to the solicitors so anyway I'm
gonna check out now if you enjoyed the
video just drop a like please drop a
comment subscribe to the channel because
I'm always giving nuggets and pearls of
wisdom about property investing on this
channel every single day I've got stuff
to say about property so subscribe if
you want to be a property investor or if
you are and you want to take things to
the next level I'll see you soon thanks
for watchin
you